okay this morning I want to talk to you
about the assassination of President
Kennedy certainly one of the most famous
crimes in American history and what I
want to do today is to illustrate
aspects of the assassination part of our
controversy because ever since it
happened on November 22nd 1963 there has
been a tremendous amount of disagreement
among researchers about whether or not
the Kennedy assassination resulted from
the work of a lone assassin as the
Warren Commission claimed or that of a
conspiracy as most researchers who have
studied the subject claim and the best
way to do that I think is to illustrate
some of the aspects of the assassination
with a series of photos and I think that
any reasonable person would conclude
that the evidence overwhelmingly proves
that there was a conspiracy now there is
another side to the story and in my book
the JFK assassination debates I do bring
out the other side of the story as well
those who believe that the accused
assassin Lee Harvey Oswald did it all by
himself but in fact I don't agree with
that and most researchers don't do not
agree with that so let's begin by taking
a look at what happened President
Kennedy was riding in a motorcade in
downtown Dallas Texas the motorcade had
just gone through the main part of
downtown Dallas had turned from Main
Street made a right-hand turn onto
Houston Street traveled one block and
then turned left made a sharp left-hand
turn onto Elm Street and what you see
here on this first photograph is the
motorcade the Kennedy limousine is the
first vehicle directly behind it is a
Secret Service car the third car the
white the
a dark-colored car is the car for Vice
President Lyndon Johnson and behind it
the white car is that for the Secret
Service follow-up one of the most
interesting aspects of this case I
believe is the fact that even after the
first shot was fired and this photograph
was taken after the first shot was fired
The Secret Service riding in Kennedy's
limousine did not react the driver of
the limousine actually slowed down after
the first shot and the Secret Service
agent sitting in the right front seat
and you see a clear shot of him later on
did nothing throughout the shooting
sequence by way of contrast Vice
President Lyndon Johnson and his car a
Secret Service agent sitting in the
right front seat immediately after the
first shot jumped into the back seat not
Johnson to the floor and covered him
with his body why the lack of reaction
by Kennedy's Secret Service agents and
the response by Johnson's has never been
established take next picture here is a
photograph of the front entrance to the
Texas schoolbook depository building
located to the right rear where the
limousine was at the time of the
shooting this is the entranceway that
according to the Warren Commission Lee
Harvey Oswald the accused assassin
walked out onto the front sidewalk three
minutes after the shooting and then
Oswald walked down to your right seven
blocks down Elm Street and caught a bus
okay next
photograph
here is a photograph showing a railroad
yard and to the upper left a part of a
parking lot this is located behind an
area known as the grassy knoll which was
located to the right front of where the
limousine was located at the time of the
shooting the grassy knoll
is the source of many people who myself
included who believed that at least one
of the shots came from there one minute
after the shots were fired a Dallas
police officer like many other people
ran up to in the direction of the grassy
knoll he climbed over a wooden fence and
saw man trying to get into a parking lot
the man into one of the cars in the
parking lot the man got into the car he
the Secret Service I mean the police
officer stopped him the man pulled out
Secret Service identification and then
he drove off
we know he was not a real Secret Service
agent all genuine Secret Service agents
remain with the motorcade on their race
to Parkland Hospital in Dallas so
somebody was impersonating the Secret
Service agents on the parking lot behind
the grassy knoll a minute after the
shooting okay next slide here is the
front entrance to Parkland Hospital
emergency room area okay next photograph
here is the first of several slides I'm
going to show you to illustrate the
almost unbelievable lack of care taken
dealing with criminal evidence in this
case we have a case here where the
President of the United States John F
Kennedy and the governor of Texas John
Connally were shot if anything
great care should have been taken to
preserve evidence but in fact this was
not done the clothing of a gunshot wound
victim is very important evidence in a
homicide case here we see a Texas
congressman carrying Vice I mean
governor Conley's clothing out of the
emergency room entrance governor
Conley's clothing were taken to his
house given to mrs. Connelly she waited
a couple of months nobody did anything
so she sent it to a dry cleaners which
of course obliterated any evidentiary
value it may have had to begin with and
finally only after it had been dryclean
was Conley's shirt and undershirt and
suit jacket taken by the authorities and
examined okay next one another scene
outside the emergency room entrance to
Parkland Hospital okay next slide here's
another example of the lack of proper
police procedures in a criminal case
everybody has seen CSI law and order and
other programs of that kind you know the
very first thing that happens in a
criminal case when the police arrive on
the scene what do they do
they seal off the scene of the crime
with the yellow crime-scene tape at no
time was Dealey Plaza ever sealed off
here a photograph taken 15 minutes after
the shooting
you see traffic proceeding on Elm Street
as if nothing had happened
spectators wandering in and out of
Dealey Plaza without being questioned by
the authorities no serious search was
made of evidence to find evidence in
Dealey Plaza the very next day after the
assassination an 18 year old college
student found a piece of President
Kennedy's skull in the median on the
other side of Elm Street no search had
been made okay next photograph
here if you can raise that just a tiny
bit I don't know we can't but anyway the
a fer don't go back that's okay we can
see it this photograph was taken about
15 seconds after the assassination it's
a blow-up of a photograph of the Texas
schoolbook depository building taken by
one of the photographer's in the back of
the press motorcade he heard shots and
was simply shooting scenes of Dealey
Plaza and this is a blow-up the a
half-open window on the upper right is
the window the sixth floor southeast
corner went window from which the Warren
Commission claims Lee Harvey Oswald
fired all the shots yet directly beneath
the sixth floor window you see two men
looking out of the fifth floor window
and clearly and obviously neither man is
reacting as if any shots had been fired
from the from directly above their heads
okay next photograph here is a view of
the inside of the Texas School Book
Depository sixth floor the whole sixth
floor was one big room it was a storage
or a warehouse type facility where boxes
of school textbooks were located okay
next photograph here's another the
bottom photograph shows another view of
the sixth floor of the Book Depository
building you can see all the stacks of
cartons of school textbooks these are
elementary school mathematics reading
and so forth textbooks for schools the
upper photograph shows the view from the
sixth floor window of the Book
Depository building that an assassin say
Lee Harvey Oswald or anyone else
would have had of Elm Street okay next
photograph here is a photograph taken
through the telescopic sight of Oswald's
rifle from the sixth floor window
there's an FBI reenactment vehicle
that's concealed by the leaves of a live
oak tree from the sixth floor an
assassin who wanted to fire a shot would
have had to wait until the vehicle had
moved from behind the leaves of the live
oak tree because nobody would seriously
shoot at this particular point because
you simply can't see there two FBI
agents sitting in this vehicle
simulating Kennedy's and Conley's
positions okay
here we have an interesting couple of
slides both of them taken directly from
the Warren Commission's own evidence the
upper photograph shows the a view from
the sixth floor window of the FBI
reenactment vehicle the white
convertible when it was on Houston
Street heading towards the Book
Depository building the bottom
photograph taken through the telescopic
sight of Lee Harvey Oswald's rifle shows
the kind of shot that Oswald would have
had had he fired when the limousine was
in this position and you can see clearly
for yourself that a lone assassin nobody
else involved no other gunmen would
obviously have fired now because there's
a point-blank shot right between the
eyes of Kennedy why would a lone
assassin wait for this limousine to turn
the car to make a sharp left-hand turn
then drive past the live oak tree that
we just saw and then go from behind pass
the live oak tree and then have a shot
only of the top
of Kennedy's back in the back of his
head when it had he would have a perfect
shot right here right between the eyes
this questions never been answered okay
another example of the lack of handling
of evidence outside the emergency room
entrance to Parkland Hospital in Dallas
where Kennedy and Connally were taken
you can see for yourself dozens if not
hundreds of people swarming all around
touching vehicles that were in the
motorcade no attempt made to for crowd
control two bullet fragments belonging
to Lee Harvey Oswald's rifle were
allegedly found on the front seat of
Kennedy's limousine I say allegedly
because we don't have any photographs of
them in place another failure of to file
a proper police procedure and why would
they not photograph them in place if
indeed fragments were found but it's
very interesting to note that at
approximately the same time when all of
these people are milling around here
with the opportunity for somebody to
plank bullet fragments in the limousine
Jack Ruby Lee Harvey Oswald's killer was
seen at Parkland Hospital by two
separate witnesses okay
next photograph another view of the
sixth floor of the Texas schoolbook
depository building taken about two
minutes after the shooting the second
window from the top on the right is the
window from which Oswald allegedly fired
the shots if you recall the previous
photograph I showed you and look at this
photograph you can see how boxes of
school textbooks have actually been
rearranged
differently from those that were in the
previous photograph somebody moved boxes
around in the minute the two-minute time
period after the shooting and it could
not have been Lee Harvey Oswald
because Oswald was elsewhere at the time
and here's a very interesting point one
minute and 30 seconds after the shooting
two people a Dallas police officer and
the superintendent and the book
depository building saw Lee Harvey
Oswald in a second-floor lunchroom
standing in front of a Coke machine so
if you believe the lone assassin thesis
then Oswald must have fired the shots
walked all the way across the sixth
floor of the Book Depository building
from the southeast corner to the
northwest corner remember it covers a
whole floor of the building gone down
four flights of stairs gone into a
lunchroom took a nickel out of his
pocket yes cokes cost a nickel
in 1963 put it in the Coke machine got a
Coke out and was drinking a coke before
the officer and the his boss saw him
there it's an Oswald according to both
of them was not out of breath who was
not agitated or nervous or anything a
man who has just killed the President of
the United States and wounded the
governor of Texas okay next the only
eyewitness who claims to have seen Lee
Harvey Oswald firing a shot said that
Oswald was standing up when he was
firing and you can see clearly here a
police officer standing next to the
window a normal-sized man could not
possibly have fired through from that
window without shooting through glass
because the window was
but only 15 inches from the lens which
goes all the way down to the floor
it wasn't even at knee height and
therefore this witness who wasn't
wearing his glasses at the time could
not possibly have been accurate
okay next photo immediately after the
shooting witnesses in Dealey Plaza began
running in the direction of the grassy
knoll which was be to the right front of
where the limousine was at the time it's
to your upper-left looking at this
photograph here why people run towards
the scene of shooting I don't know but
nevertheless it happens frequently okay
next slide once again another view of
traffic on Elm Street 15 to 20 minutes
after the shooting people milling about
walking around people wandering in and
out of daily plans and nobody is stopped
by the authorities the scene of the
crime is not sealed off it's just almost
mind-boggling to think about the lack of
just fundamental police procedure here
but nevertheless it did happen
okay next photograph here is the rifle
that Lee Harvey Oswald is supposed to
have used to kill President Kennedy
it's a bolt-action Italian rifle a
mannlicher-carcano six and a half
millimeter which equates to 25 caliber
in American terminology
it's a bolt-action rifle meaning you
have to cut the bolt of the rifle fire a
shot and then cut the boat again before
you fire another shot okay next slide
the first of several slides from there's
a protocol
a man named Abraham Zapruder was
standing between the Book Depository in
the grassy knoll to the right front of
where the limousine was and filmed the
motorcade focusing of course on the
Kennedy limousine
here Kennedy is simply smiling and
waving to the crowds nothing has
happened yet the limousine proceeds
forward next photograph it continues to
proceed forward next photograph until it
disappears behind a street sign and then
reappears behind the street zone for one
second in actual time okay next
photograph now we can see President
Kennedy appear sometime during that
one-second heat that the limousine was
behind the streets on Kennedy was hit by
the first shot
Kennedy's hands are moving up towards
his face he begins wincing in pain
Jacqueline Kennedy seen it to Kennedy's
left starts to look over towards him
because she has heard the shot okay here
we have a wide-angle view this is how
the actual Zapruder film looks a wide a
the whole lemon scene is in focus here
okay next a blow-up of the same slide
that we just saw Kennedy has obviously
been hit he's hunched forward his hands
are going up towards his face governor
Connally seated directly in front of
President Kennedy however appears not to
have been struck at all Kennedy shows no
evidence of pain theme he is holding his
10-gallon Texas Stetson hat in his hand
and yet a fundamental part of the Warren
Commission's thesis is that at this
stage of the motorcade Connelly has been
hit by the same bullet that's going
through Kennedy according to the Warren
Commission Oswald fired a shot that
bullet went through Kennedy's neck
exited from his throat then that same
bullets went on to strike Connally in
the back
go through his chest exit from the chest
go all the way through his right wrist
shattering the radius the wrist bone and
then lodging in his left thigh Conley
shows no evidence of reaction to any of
this at this point and it's not simply
what you and I are seeing with our eyes
but the dr. Robert Shaw the thoracic
surgeon who operated on governor
Connally also said that that's
impossible for Conley to have been
struck here dr. Shaw by the way was the
head of the thoracic surgery unit from
the US Army in France during World War
two he had a great deal of experience in
treating gunshot wounds of the chest
area and yet without a single Bullet
theory of the Warren Commission the
whole lone assassin Theory collapses
like a house of cards because Oswald or
anybody else could not possibly have
gotten off two separate shots struck
Kennedy then struck Connally in the time
limitations of the Zapruder film because
we're only talking about a second and a
half in time and you can't fire two
shots from Oswald's rifle even without
aiming in less than two and a quarter
seconds okay now we move ahead Governor
Connally now begins to exhibit a
reaction to be instruct notice Connally
Conley's right shoulder hit his hair and
his cheek next slides 1/18 of a second
later
Conley's right shoulder has slumped
sharply downward his cheeks fill up with
air caused by the passage of the bullet
through the right lung collapsing the
lung and forcing air up into his mouth
and his hair flies up on his head here's
where Connally is struck a minute a
second and a half after Kennedy was
first
two separate assassins fired two
separate bullets from the rare okay
next now just before he is struck in the
head President Kennedy is leaning
slightly backward and to the left
Jacqueline Kennedy is reaching over
almost to grab him and pull him down
into her lap okay next slide now can it
is hit in the right temple area an
explosion occurs Kennedy's head blows up
almost brain tissue blood skull man
flies backward and leftwards the two
police officers writing to the on
motorcycles to the left rear of the
limousine were hit in the face with
blood and brain to sue the to Kennedy
shirt the back of his shirt was covered
with blood Kennedy himself lies
violently backward and leftward okay go
through the next few slides rather
quickly you can see how fast he goes
these are 118th of a second in duration
now he bounces off the left the back
seat and bounces forward you can see the
enormous gaping hole in the right front
area of Kennedy said most experts
believe that a an explosive bullet such
as a dum-dum bullet was fired from the
grassy knoll area from the right front
and exploded against the right front
side of Kennedy said okay the next slide
the shirt Kennedy had on when he was
struck a bullet wound of entrance a
bullet hole clearly is in the back of
the shirt the Warren Commission says
that Kennedy was struck in the back of
the neck yet the evidence of the bullet
holes in the shirt and a corresponding
hole in his suit jacket belie this
contention ok the next slide
an autopsy photograph of Kennedy's back
this is actually reversed if you picture
this reversed the bullet wound is in the
right side of the back corresponding to
where the bullet hole was in the shirt
the Warren Commission says it was in the
back of the neck but you look at the
back of the neck you see no bullet wound
at all the bullet hole is in the back of
Kennedy and since Kennedy was seated in
a normal position in the limousine he
wasn't clinched up like the photograph
the autopsy photograph shows Kennedy was
struck in the back and that bullet could
not have exited from the right from the
front of the throat as the Warren
Commission claims next photograph a
close-up view of what a bullet wound of
entrance ordinarily looks like a rather
neat round hole with a bruising around
the margins of the wound okay next here
is the bullet that the Warren Commission
claims caused the damage in Kennedy and
Connally the Warren Commission claims
that this single bullet went through
Kennedy struck Connally shattering his
fifth rib and then caused a community
fracture of the radius and emerged
totally intact without a scratch on it
it's just simply not possible ballistics
tests done with Lee Harvey Oswald's own
rifle which in which bullets were fired
into goats human cadavers wrists and
other substances clearly show that as
always happens when bullets strike hard
substances they are flattened mushroomed
they are not intact as this bullet is
okay next photograph another view of the
same bullet showing you can see all the
lands and grooves of the
bullet okay next photograph a
computer-enhanced x-ray of Kennedy's
skull showing the large degree of damage
done to the scope on the right front
side of the scope you can see how the
bones have been shattered all the way to
the back of the head and these little
white specks you see scattered
throughout the photograph the x-ray here
or pieces of bone or bullet indicating
that the bullet that struck Kennedy
fragment eyes which is not the kind of
ammunition Oswald is supposed to have
used okay next load here is a x-ray
taken from the front showing the same
thing except that you can see it from a
different perspective but the very large
area of the right front portion of the
skull was shattered to pieces you can
see in the different planes of the skull
the skull the different little white
specks of bone and bullet fragment a
massive explosion occurred on Kennedy's
skull Oswald's copper-jacketed
ammunition simply does not cause that
kind of wound you need other kind of
ammunition to do that
okay next photograph a photograph
actually this is a drawing made from a
photograph showing the back of Kennedy's
head some Warren Commission defenders
claimed that that hole you see near the
very top of the back of the head the at
the back of the hairline there near the
Kollek is a bullet wound of entrance and
if you look over to the right front you
can see a large flap of scalp hanging
actually it looks over but in front of
the right there
next photograph a autopsy photograph of
Kennedy lying on the table at the morgue
showing matted brain manner in the top
of in the hair next photograph
another view this is a photograph here
showing Kennedy's head autopsy
pathologist is raising the head up with
his hand here instead of proper autopsy
photographs being made the whole
post-mortem on Kennedy was done in a
very incompetent manner no experienced
professional forensic pathologist was
present instead it was all done in
secrecy and pathetic Naval Hospital
outside of Washington
okay next photograph another photograph
showing the top of Kennedy's head next
photograph the right side of Kennedy
said autopsy photographs and x-rays
conflict with each other okay next slide
here you can see taken from the top look
below Kennedy's Adam's apple in the neck
area you see a very large gaping hole
that the Warren Commission claims is a
bullet hole of exit from the bullet that
entered the back of the neck in fact
when Kennedy was brought into the ER at
Parkland Hospital in Dallas Kennedy had
a tiny little puncture wound in the
front of the throat just below the
Adam's apple the wound according to the
Dallas doctors and nurses who treated
him was four by six or three by five
millimeters in size one-fifth by 1/8 of
an inch in other words that's a bullet
wound of entrance which they all fought
during the emergency resuscitation
measures performed on Kennedy one of the
Dallas surgeons did a tracheotomy
incision right through that wound now a
tracheotomy incision odd ordinarily is
made with a scalpel it is cut through
just wide enough to insert the
endotracheal tubes
to the breathing apparatus of the body
of course this looks like a meat grinder
went through because by the time the
body left Dallas and arrived at the
morgue in Bethesda that tiny little hole
with the tiny little trach incision
suddenly has become a wide gaping wound
that is made to look like a bullet wound
of exits when in fact it's not okay
next slide here's Lee Harvey Oswald the
accused assassin of President Kennedy
Oswald's rifle was found on the sixth
floor of the depository building several
finger prints of Oswald's were found on
the nineteen book cartons found near the
sixth floor southeast corner window
although Oswald worked in the Book
Depository so it's finger prints there
of course mean no more than yours and my
fingerprints do in this classroom and I
might add that while three prints of
Oswald's were found 24 prints of Dallas
police officers were found on the same
boxes give you another idea of the
handling of evidence in this case Oswald
was arrested in a movie theater at
approximately 1:15
I mean 1:45 p.m. a Dallas police officer
JD Tippit had been killed and in a
residential area of Dallas four miles
from Dealey Plaza Oswald was arrested in
a movie theater and taken to Dallas
Police Headquarters where he was
originally charged with shooting the
police officer but later he was charged
with killing Kennedy as well Oswald was
not given the legal rights that people
accused of committing crimes or
ordinarily entitled to such as having an
attorney present at all times and as you
can see he was forced to answer
reporters questions okay next slide
once again Oswald in custody and Dallas
police headquarters the evening of the
assassination two days after the
assassination before a nationwide
audience on live television as Lee
Harvey Oswald was being led out of
Police Headquarters into the basement
parking garage a man named Jack Ruby
rushed out of a crowd of police officers
and journalists and fired one shot into
Oswald's abdomen the bullet penetrated
through several internal organs causing
massive internal hemorrhaging Oswald was
rushed to Parkland Hospital where
emergency surgery was performed on him
by many of the same doctors who treated
Kennedy by the way but the same result
happened Oswald died during surgery Jack
Ruby had a long history of ties to
organized crime
but the Warren Commission concluded that
Ruby's action was that of an act of
impulse in other words the official
explanation is that we have two lone
gunmen in this case Oswald killed
Kennedy wounded Connelly and then killed
a Dallas police officer of Plus Ruby
killed Oswald neither one of them was
put up to their acts by anybody else
there was no conspiracy of any kind as
the official version okay next slide one
of the few pieces of evidence that was
handled carefully in this case was a
fried chicken lunch found on the sixth
floor of the Book Depository one of the
african-american men who worked on the
fifth floor and you saw his picture in a
slide I showed you was eating a fried
chicken lunch on the sixth floor and
after he finished he simply threw his
chicken bones in wax paper and paper bag
and Dr Pepper bottle on the floor there
he got up and left and by the way he was
no more than 15 feet from where Oswald
was
supposedly awaiting Kennedy and said he
saw and heard no one and it turns out
that this evidence was meaningless
because it had nothing to do with the
assassination two people saw Oswald with
a paper bag in his hand
okay next look and both of the morning
of the assassination both of the
witnesses said that the paper bag Oswald
KarenT was a normal sized brown paper
bag like you would get from a
supermarket or other department store
whatever approximately two feet long
give or take an inch or two the Warren
Commission claims that this is the bag
that I was law carried into the Book
Depository the morning of the
assassination a paper bag more than
three feet long quite obvious it's hard
to forget because it's even when
disassembled to the rifle that Oswald
had could could not fit into a package
less than three feet long and therefore
Lee Harvey Oswald had to according to
the official version carry the rifle
into the building in that bag on the
morning of the assassination now to wrap
up there's a tremendous amount of
controversy about the Kennedy
assassination one of the questions
that's intrigued me all of these years
as a historian is that if indeed there
were no conspiracy if Lee Harvey Oswald
did it all by himself if there's nothing
to hide then why was there this massive
cover-up of evidence in the case in the
Kennedy assassination case there has
been and still continues to this day
a cover-up of evidence in 1993 as a
result of popular reaction to the
Oliver Stone movie JFK President Clinton
appointed a an assassination records
Review Board to release documents on the
Kennedy assassination still withheld by
the government and more than four
million pages of documents that had been
classified were released four million
pages of documents not to mention films
photographs and other pieces of evidence
in this case and once again I would go
back to that fundamental question why
cover it up okay we have time left for a
question-and-answer session so I'd like
some volunteers to ask questions I know
you must have some questions and if you
would go to the microphone who's got a
question okay go on
okay Sarah you go ahead first who is be
a volunteer
I actually have a couple of questions
okay um if there was a scheme and her
conspiracy to do this was the whole
Dallas Police Department involved no no
I I didn't in the time I had I was being
unfair of course obviously the
overwhelming majority of members of the
Dallas police force and for that matter
other agencies government agency FBI
Secret Service CIA you name it are
honest ordinary loyal patriotic American
citizens had nothing to do with any kind
of cover-up why the neglect of
fundamental police procedures like not
even sealing off the scene of the crime
I don't know but it didn't happen okay
and wood as Wald would he have
volunteered to do this or was he chosen
by someone how did he end up being the
fall guy or was he set up well I don't
know is the answer that I have to give
you to this question because Oswald
could have fired a shot of course Oswald
could have fired a shot he could have
been part of a conspiracy or he could
have been as he himself told the press
the evening of the assassination I'm a
patsy a scapegoat set up to take the
blame of the real assassins got away
Kennedy Kennedy's assassination has
never been explained
and the what I think happened is that
Oswald was a scapegoat that he really
didn't have anything to do with it but
with his background
Oswald was a defector to the Soviet
Union he had connections to CIA related
activities dealing with anti-castro
activities and the like
he became the perfect fall guy to take
the blame while the real people who
killed Kennedy got away with it okay
morning dr. Kurtz more conspiracy
theorists have always speculated about
an involvement here in New Orleans
especially with Carlos Marcello's what
if any do you believe that Carlos Marcel
did carlos Marcello's play in the JFK
assassination well I think there's
certainly a possibility Carlos Marcello
the mafia boss in Louisiana and Santo
Trafficante the mafia boss in Florida
are the two main organized crime
suspects in the Kennedy assassination
Marcelo specifically because Dallas fell
within Marcello's empire Texas was part
of his organized crime syndicate that he
would have had to give permission before
Kennedy was killed if indeed it was an
organized crime hit on Kennedy Jack Ruby
worked for people who were very close to
carlos marcello in fact
ruby made frequent trips to new orleans
where he met with many of the
proprietors of strip joints and other
establishments on Bourbon Street and the
like and was closely connected and
indeed made more than three dozen
telephone calls to organized crime
figures in the New Orleans area in the
three-month period before the Kennedy
assassination
on his deathbed Santos traffic country
the Florida mafia boss told a close
associate of his that I'm going to
pretty up the language here that Carlos
messed up he should have killed Bobby
but instead he killed Giovanni
the Italian of course for John and
coming from the lips of one of the most
fearsome mafia bosses in the history of
organized crime Santo Trafficante
that has to be given some credit
credibility and of course Jack Ruby
killing Oswald this has all thought
hallmarks of an organized crime hit as
well to silence him to prevent a trial
from taking place to microphone okay we
got one here okay morning
I have two questions suppose Connelly
ever interviewed by the Warren
Commission and what did he say governor
Connally was indeed interviewed by the
Warren Commission governor Connally
insistent that he was struck by a
separate shot than the one that struck
President Kennedy Conley said and what
he says is verified by the Zapruder film
that he heard the first shot fired and
he started to turn around to look at
Kennedy seated directly behind him and
he didn't see anything and so he was
going to turn the other way to see
Kennedy but when he started to turn back
that's when the second shot hit him he
was absolutely positive that the second
shot struck him and only him in the
first shot struck Kennedy and Connally
had experience as a hunter he knew the
sounds of gunfire he said he never heard
the second shot because of course
bullets move faster than the speed of
sound and so the impact of the shot on
him so Conley's testimony
is strong evidence in and of itself
against the single Bullet theory and the
you mentioned officer Tippit who was
killed is there any connection with that
with the assassination and do you in
fact believe that Oswald even had
anything to do with that it's impossible
to say for sure but Oswald was at the
scene of the tippet killer whether he
killed tip it or not depends on a lot of
factors that I didn't have time to go
into but basically several witnesses
claimed to have seen Lee Harvey Oswald
Shipp tippet although there were several
other witnesses who saw more than one
person at the scene of the tippet
killing firing shots and so you have two
different versions here bullets from
Tippett's body removed from officer
tippets body were two mutilated to match
any of the bullets to match Oswald's 38
caliber revolver that he had with him
when he was arrested cartridge cases
found near the scene of the tippet
killing not by the police manju of
course by spectators in the area did
match Oswald's revolver
now whether somebody planted them or not
there's no way of knowing Oswald
supposedly was walking down a sidewalk
in a quiet residential area a Dallas
police officer Tippit stopped him even
though I was well was doing nothing but
walking down the sidewalk and called him
over to his car then I was then got out
of his car and Oswald pulled out his gun
and shot him dead and then ran off
but there's a lot of controversy about
the tippet killing I'm certainly willing
to say that Oswald may very well have
killed tippet but it's not definite
okay let's see okay okay obviously on
Debian you could give in one that's fine
okay obviously Governor Connally had to
turn around after he heard the shot
uh-uh-uh-uh
the president's wife Jacqueline Kennedy
she was she had a full field of view of
him and what is her opinion had was she
questioned did she come in because yes
most questioned but her what she said
really did not make much sense knowing
the facts that we do and it's
understandable
I mean her husband's head was blown off
practically in her own lap and she was
in a state of shock
immediately after the fatal head shot
Jacqueline Kennedy actually crawled out
onto the trunk of the limousine and
almost fell off had it not been for a
Secret Service agent from the follow-up
car who ran and got on to the trunk and
pulled her back into the back seat of
the limousine so I she didn't really you
know what she said didn't really has no
impact at all on this case I don't think
he mentioned the Secret Service agent
that didn't do anything whenever Kennedy
was shot was it ever insinuated or
mentioned that maybe he had something to
do with it that maybe was paid off or
anything like though not know and I
don't I don't want to insinuate that
myself either because of course I don't
know but certainly he neglected his duty
like the city no not at all and that's
amazing because the Secret Service are
trained to react instantaneously like
the one who jumped into the backseat of
Johnson's car and covered him with his
body and the Secret Service agent who
protected President Reagan after he was
shot once jumped in front of Reagan and
took the second bullet that Hinckley
fired and so forth but no real
investigation was made into the neglect
by either him or the driver of the
lemons
mean like I said who slow down after the
first shot was fired instead of
accelerating okay finger prints found on
a sixth floor what uh I know I've read
that they found other fingerprints that
didn't belong there
they found that lease officers that was
the under print on those boxes that
didn't belong to any known individual
and was not on the FBI's master file of
fingerprints and so somebody who had no
business touching any of those boxes did
touch it now who knows who it was though
but there are strange questions about
these fingerprints also I want to talk
about the paper bag too I witnessed say
they sell Oswald holding a paper bag
between his underarm and his cuff of his
hand right there I wrote that paper bag
didn't seem like no could hold that oh
he would have had to be an orangutan to
hold it like that I mean even a man my
size it's not you can picture a
yardstick which is the length of that
paper bag there it's impossible to hold
one end cuffed under your hand and the
other under your armpit like that
without some of it would have to stick
up over your shoulder and it simply was
not that way all right uh and also can
you tell us what the involvement of uh
David Ferrie and Clay Shaw had into the
other with the Oswald and David Ferrie
David Ferrie and Clay Shaw were two
characters in the Jim Garrison
investigation into the assassination
that was the feature part of the movie
JFK of course New Orleans District
Attorney Jim Garrison investigated the
assassination and concluded there was a
conspiracy hatched in New Orleans and
that David Ferrie a former Eastern
Airlines pilot and a rather strange
character and Clay Shaw a retired
prominent member of the New Orleans
business and civic community were
involved in a conspiracy with Lee Harvey
the conspiracy to assassinate Kennedy
and on the very day that investigators
from Garrison's office went to fairy's
apartment in New Orleans to arrest him
he was found dead in bed one of many
mysterious deaths in this case that have
never been confirmed by anybody uh and
Clay Shaw was eventually tried for
conspiracy to murder John Kennedy in
1969 but he was acquitted unanimously
acquitted by the jury and I think quite
rightly because garrison simply did not
produce the evidence to convict Shaw
okay was the bullet that struck Connelly
intended for Kennedy and he got in the
way when he was turning around to look
at it I think that whoever fired
certainly intended to hit Kennedy but
struck Connally instead because after
the first shot that you saw Kennedy move
like that with his hands going up
towards his head I think that the gunman
simply missed
I mean it's conceivable of course since
we don't know what was in the minds of
these people that one of them intended
to kill Connally as well but I don't
think so I think it's reasonable to say
that Kennedy was the real target the
medical records as well as testimony
from various witnesses and other people
who may or may not have been involved
how much of that was released and do you
think the ones that weren't released do
you think at any given time that they
will be released to the public these
autopsy photographs I showed you provide
a perfect example had it not been for
the fact that a Secret Service agent
made a copy of the autopsy photographs
for himself and then sold them to a
researcher in 1982 we wouldn't have
access to them even to this day because
the originals are still being suppressed
they belong to the Kennedy family by the
why not to the government and the
Kennedy family won't let anybody except
a few select individuals look at the
originals and why the Kennedy family has
custody of them I don't know because
they don't have custody Safer of the
Robert Kennedy autopsy photographs in
California but anyway other medical
records were suppressed as well
including x-rays tissues slides and
various other things many of them have
totally disappeared off the face of this
earth and I don't think we'll ever find
out I don't think anything of substance
is going to be released any time at
least in our lifetimes as you had said
before in 1993 four million pages of
information had been released to the
public was there any part of that
information in the four million pages
that we didn't already know from the
Warren Commission there was a lot of
information about activities involving
CIA mafia assassination plots against
Fidel Castro that was already known but
more details have come out there was
more information about Lee Harvey
Oswald's two and a half years he stayed
in the Soviet Union
information dealing with organized crime
no smoking gun material to say hey this
is the key to the Kennedy assassination
we can put an end to it and say this is
what exactly what happens like I tell my
students in my JFK assassination class
we don't know who killed John Kennedy
and what I don't think we'll ever know
the whole truth about it but I think
most of these documents do help to
reinforce the conspiracy theory okay
dr. Kerr she mentioned that the Warren
Commission founded that Jack Ruby acted
on impulse you're killing a Lee Harvey
Oswald is there any evidence to the
contrary yes there's a lot of evidence
to the contrary ruby was stalking Oswald
from the time-outs Waldron's arrest like
I said ruby was seen at Parkland
Hospital
not long after Kennedy was brought there
to begin with on the evening of the
assassination ruby actually got a press
badge from one of his friends in the
dallas police force and was at a press
conference for Oswald but he was so far
back but so many reporters and
microphones and cameras in front of him
that he didn't have a real opportunity
to shoot Oswald at that time ruby
appeared at Dallas Police Headquarters
several times bringing sandwiches and
drinks to Dallas cops many of whom knew
him personally so I think that there was
a very definite stalking of Oswald and
finally he got his real opportunity to
kill him on that Sunday morning after
the assassination but it was not an
impulsive action you also mentioned that
he may have had ties to organized crime
do we know which family he might have
had ties to well the carlos marcello
with the overall boss of the family in
dallas a man named Joseph Civello was
the head of the Dallas organized crime
family and there was a man named Joseph
Campisi
who was his underboss so to speak
Rubi operated a couple of bars and strip
joints in Dallas a lot of the Dallas
cops went there for women and booze and
what-have-you
Ruby did everything from fixing parking
tickets and other things of that kind he
was not a big man in organized crime in
other words he didn't have a family and
so he was a perfect individual to use to
kill Oswald because you couldn't trace
him the right
- Marcelo or any other major organized
crime boss even though he had links to
them thank you okay I think we're it's
10:30